venti ragazzi e bentornati a questo
nuovo ep don bentornata non ci siete mai
stati sto video che qui i benvenuti non
le facciamo introdotto anni non sono
capace non sono facile basta let's go on
anche doppiamente vediamo se riusciamo a
fare delle belle partite oggi a wish
jong e allora vincitore torneo s2 allora
giocate poi io posso il joy lei ci fate
voi non lo so ma io non ho mai non sono
ragazzi ma io non so a chi appunto
portoghese non so cosa voglia dire però
secondo me è forte perché facciamo che
appunto è meglio non dice no è vero è
vero mi dissocio
scusate io ero un interferenza noti lato
qui talmente forti che si è staccato il
microfono ed è caduto per terra
tutto a posto non hanno tranquilli
ragazza va spinto ma possibile ma basta
non entra niente
ma cos'è che solo perché sono portoghesi
sono forti non entra niente
ecco lo chiama soggiorna ecco la dieta
di solo proprio non è non ho niente miei
non si può così ha preso quel successo
non ho visto la andando sul turbo
provino agli 8 di chi fa schifosa star è
brutto perché pa rap
ma chi sono questi ho tirato malissimo
io vabbè ma fa niente riportate mentre
ben 301 proprio loro dopo aver rotto
microfono da 250 euro
è giusto che è almeno la partita sarà
portino a casa per una delle volte mi
sono fratturato il mignolo e non sto
scherzando fratturato addirittura se si
senta valso riconoscerà faccio forse che
diamo bellissima mamma mia è stato
bravissimo ad onna ragazzi in questa se
la meritavano
ma che bel tocco è vincitori dittatura
bello bello perché lo vengano a bombetta
non l'ha presa perché il pari è veloce
non l'ha presa a pugni che stasera
servono visto in pieno il gioco sì sì ho
fatto uno stop che veramente incredibile
fame da cacciare per l'unico che posso
fare è incredibile palo gol
vabbè qui tu lo sai mamma mia ragazzi
mamma mia
e dire che su rendano i nostri signori
qua complimenti bella partita bella
partita è stato a parte i pugni è stata
secondo me ci stiamo qua c'è uno in cile
inga possono essere ancora più incisiva
che vanno ancora di caso proprio vado io
però non sono andato sul palermo
destabilizzati più no ma come come ha
fatto paratona non l'ho neanche visto
sono vampata una bella questo mio dio
ecco la linea allora siamo partiti molto
bene per loro dico allora mi sono
ragazzi quattro minuti e 37
se poi i ragazzi chiedono qual è partita
la partita perché abbiamo lasciato bene
vado io vado io vado io benissimo
benissimo benissimo visto una secca
perché ne so loro tirano in porta
proprio bravo
mamma mia è il momento di essere in chi
comanda guardava dal basso
però niente socio oggi mi sono fatto
niente 30 punti complimenti
no no previsto prova demolirlo non sono
uscita demoliremo neanche la presa paolo
palo tutti i core cosa che cosa è
successo cosa è successo di questo è
venuto fuori
ma cos'è stati spesi amante 3 questo sì
se non conosci diamante 3 euro so in che
paese siano tante travi di attenzione
bellissimo gol del fava incredibile per
niente inaspettato distrutto imbattuta
ma mia spizzica gliela proprio così no
però tornata sembra incredibile lancerò
via va bene questo tenterà il pilot per
londra passa al centro come giocano i
ragazzi per il soggetto allora cosa sei
visto giorgio di tirare fuori il tuo
stand
ma che dici tutto che sapevo vi saltava
fuori bene bella bella
dai che ce la dà che c'era i marinai
invece il passaggio in mezzo che è un
bijoux rischio con fossi confonde till
it's i cofanetti le truffe e vabbè
niente non ci arriverò mai però è un bel
controllino belluno che in mezzo alla
gente
non vedo le persone dove stanno usato da
pollica non glielo tolgo ma non arriverò
mai invece gli arrivi ci arrivi grazie
tranquillo non ti preoccupare ci sono io
che la mette in mezzo adesso tipo ora 1
e passaggio non era perfetto
mamma mia mamma mia mamma mia mamma mia
mamma mia mamma mi aiuto sono al make up
e ma perché sono adesso adesso ce l'hai
incredibile no non è vero non è vero non
è vero ma lo prese nei loro dissocio mi
dissocio
mi disse opposte un bustino possiamo
fare secondo me a 33 secondi
sì possiamo possiamo vedere al ideali e
cava cà trenta secondi per sognare non è
male il tocco a calori tranquillo
bellissimo bellissimo bellissimo veli ma
questi come sarà sicuramente joystick
bagnatissimo volta però forse quella
arriva non lo so ti prego facciamo
qualcosa non gliela soltanto pareggiare
non mi attivero era nel mare questo è
buono aspetta aspetta aspetta turbo ma
non ci sono no non mi ha conosciuto dei
nais del controllo minuti con tumori
neanche visto aspettava lo dico niente
guerriero attenzione
mamma mia no è fuori però andato
credendoci sempre di porto
niente dai centri totalmente free si
demoliscono leva tv rai volevo dirti per
cattiveria
niente ma dei fake o mio di melo prima
specchio magari te lo dicono molto prima
funzionato nello spazio di mare
hai aspettato cioè trasto tutto e se per
caso la prova controllare è la
resistenza va bene parole che non lo
faccio la l'angolino
proprio lui mamma mia mamma mia
i ragazzi vedono l'aggressività e di
come possiamo tenere testa e si segnano
da soli è quello che dobbiamo fare
apple fake guarda ci sta ci sta perfetto
ho fatto a bassina perché mi mettono
diamante che sono bronzo due perché si
sa nella chi non funziona perché mamma
mia il doppio dribbling cacasotto
programma mar da lì piuttosto che non
prendersi un gol così
[Musica]